how about you raise your hand for
countless hours
your blood cannot bump your hands and
then you feel very sore
and painful and you were shuffled this
former worker at the uk consulate in
hong kong
claims he was tortured in chinese
detention
simon cheng fled to britain last year
and has just been granted asylum
it's not because of my background or
nationality
they believe that i have solid fear when
i back to hong kong
i'll be persecuted politically and i've
been
abducted from hong kong to mainland
china he applauded a uk decision to
offer millions of other residents
a path to citizenship after china
imposed a new
security law on hong kong but the
activist thinks britain should go
further
they need to sanction because that is
empower the people
empower the people their own view
to support the pro-democracy cost
protests were triggered in hong kong
when mr cheng disappeared on a trip to
the mainland last year
he was held for 15 days and questioned
on his work for the british government
did they think that you worked for mi6
yeah
they asked do you know what is mi5 mi6
uh of course i don't know and i'm just a
i was just a junior staff and
and they asked how dare you
how dare you to work for the british to
supervise
chinese you're chinese your traitor
mr cheng says he was forced to make a
false confession
that he'd paid for prostitutes it was
aired along with this video
of him at a massage parlor britain
accuses china
of torturing mr cheng but beijing
insists
all his rights were protected now he's
focused on supporting his
birth city from his new home in london
we're on front line to deal with not
only other terrorism now gonna be
totally terrorism and they're gonna
expand
to hong kong and we fight and we give a
warning signal to the world
now and we buy time for the world
to cope with it to to deal with it and i
do believe that's the
hong kong citizens can should gets the
nobel peace prize even though he's left
mr cheng still thinks he's being
monitored
uncertain times for this unusual refugee
debra haynes sky news